are you
afraid of uh your own mortality
we two humans sitting here yeah
i do you think do you ponder your
mortality i mean you're
somebody who thinks about your brain a
lot it
seems one of the more um
terrifying or i don't know
i don't know how to feel about it but it
seems to be one of the most definitive
aspects of
life is that it ends it's a complicated
answer but i think the best i can do in
a short
snippet would be to say for a very long
time i did not fear my own mortality
i feared the i feared pain
and suffering so that that's what i
feared
i feared being harmed or dying in a way
that would be painful
um but i didn't fear having my life be
over now
as a mother i i think i
i have fear i fear dying before
my daughter is um
[Music]
ready to be without me
that's what i fear it's
that's that's really what i fear and
frankly honestly
i fear my husband dying before me much
more than i fear my own death
there's that love and social attachment
again yeah because i know
i it's i know it's just gonna i'm gonna
feel like i wish i was dead
yeah a final question about life
uh what do you think is the meaning of
it all
what's the meaning of life
yeah i think that there isn't one
meaning of life there's like many
meanings of life
and you know you use different ones on
different days but for me
depending on the day depending on the
day but for me i would say
um sometimes the meaning of life is to
understand
to make meaning actually the meaning of
life is to make meaning
um sometimes it's that sometimes it's
to um leave the world just slightly a
little bit better
than it like the johnny appleseed view
you know
sometimes um the meaning of life
is um to um
you know like clear the path
for my daughter or for my students
you know it's to you know so sometimes
it's that
and sometimes it's just um
you know like you know your moments
where
you're looking at the sky or
you're you know by the ocean
or sometimes for me it's even like i'll
see
um you know like a
weed poking out of a crack in a sidewalk
you know
and you just have this overwhelming
sense of the
like wonder of the um
of the world like the world is like just
like the physical world is so
wondrous and you you just get very
immersed in the
moment the moment like the sensation of
the moment
sometimes that's the meaning of life i
don't i don't think there's one meaning
of life
i think it's a population of instances
just like uh
just like any other category i don't
think there's a better way to end it
lisa the first time we spoke is um
i think if not the then one of
i think it's the first conversation i
had that basically launched this pocket
yeah that's actually the first
conversation i had to launch this
podcast
and now we get to finally do it uh the
right way so
it's a huge honor to talk to you that
you spent time with me
uh i can't wait for hopefully the many
more books you'll write
certainly can't wait to uh i already
read this
this book but i can't wait to listen to
it because as you said offline
that you're reading it and i think you
have a great voice you have a great i
don't know
what the nice way to put it but maybe
npr voice
in the best version of what that is so
thanks again for talking today always my
pleasure thank you so much for
for having me back
you